stepping into his back and backside took
his legs and she's been a single step
one centimeter it's been reported is a
young man I think he's been stabbed in
the neck by an assailant who has driven
away from the scene it's the start of
the night shift for critical care
paramedic Tom waters and dr. Richard
Brown
but the problem is at the moment we
don't have any police to go to the scene
to make sure it's safe so we're just
waiting for that updates are coming in
all the time
it's a female he's been stuck okay so
the place at the seed so we're gonna go
there's a young female I believe it is
who's got a puncture wound to the neck
they arrived and frying the woman with a
stab wound near her collarbone so what
we're trying to ascertain is how far
that's that's gone in to your into a
less ideal she's treated and once
they're happy her injuries aren't too
serious she's taken to hospital four
checks
yeah that's all we saved many thanks
within minutes there's another period so
is reports of a male who's missed out
repeatedly in the leg there's been two
calls on this job which usually means
it's potentially significant and the
sudden report they might be unconscious
but we're not clear really at the moment
the police are already there it's
clearly a crime scene the young man is
unconscious he's lost a lot of blood
let's roll him on so we can have a look
at it they managed to bring him round
we're gonna get you downstairs in a
moment to the ambulance we're gonna take
you outside yeah we're clear it's not
even three hours and two Richard and Tom
shift we're getting more and more
stabbings and essentially I think it's
more and more younger children younger
younger adults and children who are
getting involved with the stabbings is
probably the experience the teams having
at the moment unfortunately because it's
not really a rare occurrence it's more
of a common thing then I think as a team
we're not really surprised by anything
these days the next call is to a fight
in Upton upon seventh it becomes clear
the injuries aren't severe what report
on a stab wound it's actually just a
minor wounds whose leg they leave those
needing treatment to other ambulance
crews back on the road
they're alerted to a serious stabbing
that's just happened in Coventry so mob
lot of patients are made and they all
seem to be in a teenagers 15 16
most seriously injured there's a
fifteen-year-old who's been stabbed and
my entirely sure where but they've had a
cardiac arrest at the scene the crew
managed to resuscitate them and it
sounds obvious he lost a significant
amount of blood several other crews are
closer and are being sent to as they
drive they're getting updates from the
paramedics on the ground the crew at the
scene have been told to get the boy to
hospital as quickly as possible
Richard and Tom meet them there despite
the best efforts of doctors and
paramedics the boy dies a short time
later he was 16 year-old Jaden
Washington James another young victim of
knife crime another family and community
bereft paramedic Colin Apps takes over
for the day shift he's been briefed on
what happened overnight it's not nice to
see you know go do our best to try and
make sure they they're going to recover
and survive these injuries but you know
it's not always the case and it's very
tragic when our life any life can be
taken but for Annika
somebody of so young with all that
future ahead of them and so much
opportunity potentially that they've
missed out on them for the rest of their
you know the rest of their life is over
then another stabbing this time in
Aubrey the man has been stabbed in the
buttocks an increasingly common injury
seen by paramedics inflicted to
humiliate the victim after a night of
Stubbings this is the first job of the
day this shows just how common stabbings
are now for paramedics I'd say we we go
to at least one stabbing a day recently
it seems to have been increasing in
numbers and I know a shift last week I
went to a free stabbings in one shooting
and one somebody that somebody that got
attacked by an axe
yes yes it seems quite common in the 24
hours we were filming there were 13
reported stabbings this is the new
normal for paramedics fighting a surge
in life crime in our cities Becky
Johnson Sky News the West Midlands